video
[Music]
at only 24 years old geraxude is aboard
a 30-foot boat sailing around the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he left his home in france two and a
half years ago to begin his journey
africa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
although he's been navigating alone he's
found an unlikely companion
company
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
riding a blind horse
that's a little different
but to me it don't make much difference
he's a pretty good friend
he's just tickled to death and he rode
i think he knows that he got eyes in and
he just jumps up and down and runs and
really likes to go
well my name's roderick olson i'm
soldiers grove wisconsin come on i have
always had a few horses matter of fact
quite a few of them
well we got jackson about 21 years ago
about 10 years ago that we noticed that
he was going blind
and as far as we can find out we've
nothing we can do about it
most old horse dealers or farmers they
used to just get rid of the horse
but i figured i'm going to keep him
i'd like to stick around a while longer
so
if i went blind i hope they keep me
around a while
[Laughter]
[Music]
i didn't figure he was useless
he does everything you want by the feel
of the reins
he's a little different riding than a
regular horse
he's careful when he's running you know
he ain't sure where his feet's going to
go or what is in front of him
but he didn't just quit because he got
blind he's trying to do things so he can
take care of himself
he trusts me
to writing
i think he just figures it man i can see
now i got eyes i can do things that i
wanted to do for a long time
he wants to just run
[Music]
he's fun for me to ride
we go all over the hills down the
canyons
in the water everywhere that any other
horse can go
he does just fine
he must trust me and well i trust him
always kind of a buddy anyhow
being friends with a horse that's a
i don't know that's the way it's been
with me all my life
i don't think they know better life than
a fisherman's life
ain't nothing like getting up before
daylight getting out on the water to see
that sun come up over the horizon we're
gonna get pulled in catfish pots in the
morning anyway yeah
we always together when we go out in
that water most of the time
everybody says they don't have two
brothers could work together many years
we have and still be working together
you give and take
[Music]
some sundays we don't see each other
but doesn't that every day
ray and i does their own thing early
every morning
we finish up right nice and we meet at
the shop
i love to see them every morning over
there
it makes a great day
[Music]
it's gonna happen one day
gonna be one morning we're not gonna be
together yep
if i go first i'll see him later
he's gonna save me a seat
if i go first i'm gonna save him one
right alongside of me
we might be fishing that bear
yeah the lord might give us some blood
fishing
catch lots of fish then
that's surreal plus the life to know
that you got somebody that is on the
same frequency you are
and
someone you could fight in and
know that
if i need a hand over there all i got to
do is call him he'll come and same with
him to me
if i didn't have a brother like him i
don't know what i'd do
did
[Music]
[Music]
together they create incredible
sculptures out of scrap metal
[Music]
this father-son duo got their start
making models of transformers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the father and son went on to expand the
business beyond just transformers and
began building their own designs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
you